So this is a pretty interesting
we've been wondering
what direction Fox News is going
to take in the post Trump era,
will they go more in the direction of the non
Trump Republicans, the direction of people like
Mitt Romney and Liz Cheney kind of
going back to the George W. Bush era?
Will Fox News go fully back in on Trump or Trump
being elected officials, the sort of Marjorie
Taylor Greene, Lauren Bobert, Madison Cauthen
direction? And there's all sorts of considerations
one way or the other. But ultimately,
we're going to have to wait and see.
Yesterday morning, the morning after Donald
Trump's bizarre and dishonest 90 minute long
speech to CPAC, the Conservative Political Action
Conference, the Fox and Friends morning show hosts
were sort of gleefully repeating Donald
Trump's clever lies about having won the 2020
election. Now, it's sort of like a lie ception
type of thing. One of the people they invited on
to talk about Trump's speech is Fox News host
Pete Hegseth. Now, Haeg, Seth was also a speaker
at CPAC. I'm going to play this clip for you.
And what what I can't totally tell here is
clearly when Pete Hegseth, the guy on the right
of the screen, reminisces about Donald Trump's
CPAC speech, lie about winning the presidential
election a third time, Pete Hegseth is definitely
being serious. When Steve Doocy repeats it, it's
less clear that Deucy is saying it as truth.
That sort of seems like Deucy is repeating it as
what it was that Trump alleges. But Pete Hegseth
is definitely serious about it. Take a look.
If that's what they wanted to hear and they wanted
to hear that there's going to be a Republican in
the big chair at the White House in four years.
Yeah, he went on to say, I think right after that
we may just have to beat them for the third time
in allusion to 2016 and 2020 because he just
took it away from me. There you go. Exactly.
Everyone in the crowd got it right away. It was
all about he talked a lot about the borders.
So, I mean, it seems like Steve Doocy is
just kind of like repeating what the claim
is. Ainslee Erhart and Brian Kilmeade just look
kind of baffled as Pete Hegseth was saying it. But
at least for now, at the bare minimum, Fox News
is allowing, if maybe not yet, fully on board
with perpetuating the lie that Joe Biden didn't
really win the 2020 presidential election. This
is a really big editorial decision to make for
Fox News. Will Fox News for the next four years
be based on the lie that Donald Trump actually
won the 2020 election? Will Fox News definitively
move away from that idea? What I think is most
likely is that Fox News will sort of play with
it. They'll sort of play coy. And what I mean by
that is their opinion. People in the evenings will
continue to kowtow to the idea that the election
wasn't really fair. Their news people will report
on the fact that, quote, Many people believe
Donald Trump actually won the 2020 election
and it'll just more or less stay in the ether
without Fox News ever taking a definitive and
clear editorial position as as a broadcast outlet.
And if they're asked about it, Fox executives will
be able to say, hey, you know, listen, each of
our shows, each of our hosts, they're allowed
to have their own opinions. They make editorial
decisions, blah, blah, blah. That's my best guess
as to what we will see on FOX as of right now.
And it'll serve a few purposes. One is it allows
them to sort of hedge and and have something that
all flavors of right wingers can find that they
agree with. It's also probably a way, legally
speaking, to avoid further lawsuit trouble.
They won't have guests on attacking
Dominion voting system specifically,
but they'll generally have some hosts continue to
put out the vague idea that many people believe
Biden didn't really win in a completely fair
way. And that way they'll be able to placate
just about anybody who's looking for something
that is marginally less crazy than Newsmax.
And on if you expect something different, let
me know. I would very much love to hear from you